I'll switch [ __ ] like dirty drugs if
if this [ __ ] don't do nothing like two
hours and I'm just changed [ __ ] you
feel me
ATM ATM where'd you grow up what
neighborhood you from Los Angeles
California
south central central and tell me about
your childhood you grew up with both
your parents actually no I grew up with
my mom no you know my mom was always
around in my uncle's as well as my great
grandfather he was a factor too he was
the way he was the factor as far as
family yet and how was your childhood
so Charles Ruffy feeling I grew up
without my dad around
so my uncle's always play father you
know I'm saying so and they had a whole
bunch of day had a whole bunch going on
so you know what I'm saying my mom was a
tough cookie - so you feel like my mom
was trying to be just like her brothers
and [ __ ] so it was just it was always
rough coming up you know my child was
always rough yeah any busey anything
like that
my mom's uh my mommy said brainy's you
know these random guys you know she
liked things like that you know from
different neighborhoods of Los Angeles
California you know what I'm saying
someone's truck had some things like
that so they used to put their hands on
my mom you know I'm saying this one guy
broke my mom-jo so you know I'm saying
as a child coming up I was always
helping my mom fight these [ __ ] off
you feel me sure that's why oh I have to
be a man fast out of young age so I'm
feeling that's what led up to here right
now you know what did three when you
went on your own wouldn't want to laugh
when you kind of boot up I got kicked
out the house when I was 14 because I
got caught - guys - 40s the same kind
film so my mom felt like I was selling
guns or some [ __ ] she filled me so she
kicked me out the house at 14 but before
then I was I put a lot on my mom so you
know I'm saying old lady
yeah
what did you do for money at that point
what I'll do some money I started
stealing I started stealing cell phones
but I always had it in the back of my
mind like my uncle's is pinchy feel me
my mom was trying to do that [ __ ] so
that's what I always wanted to be you
know what I'm saying I always wanted to
be a dope dealer and a pimp you know
what I'm saying
I was like the things I wanted to do mom
this was always coming in with different
[ __ ] you know and I'm saying all this
Jerry and you know I'm saying all of
this everything all of these cars and so
I feel like that's what I'm gonna to do
but I know how yes I started stealing
cell phones to selling the cell phones
to people you know what I'm saying he
did not started selling dope he film you
did not only be my first [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying so after I got my first
[ __ ] it was over I took off from there
you film what age was that I was a what
15 this was like the next year
you feel me I was only in the streets
like 12 months not even 20 months I'm
like that before I start before I got
cracking you feel me period and how many
girls do you have today right now I got
50 toes and what kind of girls yet all
african-american or white Hispanic
I got an Asian right now I got three
black girls
I got an Asian three black girls and I
got the white girl
so the arrangement is there you go they
make money and they give you 70
everything and what do you get what do
they get in exchange well in fact in a
matter is when dealing with prostitutes
they don't know what to do with that
money feeling so long as protection with
them they want somebody to be able to
protect them just in case they get it to
so many streets you feel me as well as
they need somebody don't know we don't
know what to do with the money so if a
female come across a guy that that's
capable of protection as well as they
know what they know how to manage the
money you know I'm saying
for example they got other hustles
besides that you feel me so they don't
they don't depend on peeping you know
what I'm saying
so it's like yeah if he sell dope he
sell weed he does this he does that you
feel what I'm saying it's like here they
can [ __ ] with you so that's that's
that's really what it's about
so yeah they gave me Ottoman you know
what I'm saying and I know what to do
with the money I got flips and PACs or
whatever I said you feel me I'll get us
apartment a place to stay vehicles you
know what I'm saying like everything we
need
are they dicta drugs some more some more
the majority of the more I try I try I
try I try to stay away from the drug
heads because it's a lot of problems you
feel me a situation saying I'm healing
so slight you supply him with the drugs
and he of course Oh God - yeah gotcha
I gonna frag off if you don't feel any
supplying the drugs I'm gonna go get it
from somewhere else it hold it right now
are you you're 30 you know so even doing
this as you're half your life since oh
yeah if you've done prison time yeah I
did four years in prison before pimping
and pandering
they dropped pimping and pandering down
to human trafficking which carries life
so I original term was 30 to life so I
had to get lawyers and spend off you
know spend all my money on lawyers and
can't get pimping and pandering no get
human trafficking death first they was
saying they got me on camera at the
Bellagio in Las Vegas they got a female
giving me $2,700 at the Bellagio so I'm
pimping so in Vegas the rules and
regulations are they don't hit you with
pimping in Panama because you're gonna
get right out so they hit you with human
trafficking so then you know what I'm
saying
long story short you know what I'm sayin
the [ __ ] kept coming like yeah that's
family and all that I he moves from
California to Vegas so he needed move in
money and all that we as people so I was
able to beat that but I got caught with
crystal meth when they raided two
apartments looking for me I got called a
crystal meth as well as I got into an
altercation with
a Las Vegas script you know what I'm
saying it was my birthday we was going
up we was doing crystalman fan you know
what I'm saying I uh it was just it was
just crazy
you know I'm saying took me for granted
and I said got ugly I grabbed a kitchen
knife it was already high on crystal
meth so it's like you know ain't nobody
thinking you know understand so yeah and
I ended up doing the worst by the grace
of God and killing you know what I'm
saying
but he ended up telling oh man yeah so
the police came and raided the apartment
saying they was I was just [ __ ] over
13 life you feel me pimping and
pandering human trafficking battery with
the use of the deadly weapon and
substantial bodily harm and possession
of sales crystal meth so with all of
that I spent I spent all the money I had
all the money my family had to get
everything dropped down and for me to
just do possession because they gave it
on my possession of sales to possession
you feel me because I told them I was
used and then holidays so I been there
and never came home so I did 48 months
though you feel me
you have kids of your own
okay yeah okay let's see
I only make [ __ ] walk the blade when
they're in trouble
ain't no money walking blade you filming
us just for a new home [ __ ] that want
some attention ain't nobody workin the
blades no more you feel me a real pimp
don't got no holes on the blade every
[ __ ] on the play is on dope they weird
you know I'm saying the best thing to do
is post ads you filmed so if you got a
like all my whole [ __ ] they got
tricks lined up that's gonna call it
calls out cause that's what's popping in
filming I ain't call that somebody who
gonna pull up on you I'll call it
somebody who wants you to pull up on
them you feel me so that's really where
the money that doesn't mean you're doing
when you post ads now that's 200 a
condom you feel me when you got [ __ ]
walking the blade they jumping in the
car but pop in $40 days he feel me
that's disgusting that's nasty now
you're bringing back infections and STDs
and your camp and all of that [ __ ] now
you not a responsible pimp you feel me
so it's levels to this [ __ ] you know I'm
saying like it's real levels to this
[ __ ] right you can you can you can be a
reckless ass pimp or you can have you
can be a classy pimp that got respect
for yourself as well as your house and
you can keep everybody clean so
everybody can be [ __ ] cuz I know I'm
[ __ ] I mean I want to hold around me
that I [ __ ] and that's weird that's
that's weird
like you feel like so if a [ __ ] don't
bring if if them
if a [ __ ] don't my [ __ ] nowadays
it's rare for my [ __ ] not to bus a day
because I'm post ads you feel me I'll
get around we post ads the phone ringing
all night so I'll make a [ __ ] Walker
blade if I'm mad at it make it walk the
blade no shoes on if I'm mad at her you
feel me I type [ __ ]
no I'm saying like it cuz [ __ ] like
to do [ __ ] do little funny [ __ ] because
this [ __ ] many more than her this night
so she got a grudge and a vendetta on
her so this week this week she was lazy
as [ __ ] you know what I'm saying and the
only reason why she was lazy because she
knows she can't beat I'll beat this
[ __ ] so it's just excuses so that's
type of [ __ ] the pimp billing wait like
[ __ ] I see with my own eyes you're not
tired he not you that's not the case you
just you know you can't be her and you
know what I'm saying so my [ __ ] post
ads so I don't really have to worry
about them you feel me yeah because
[ __ ] if I pay one hundred and sixty
dollars for a room bed she better
somebody better make it back you feel me
somebody better make you back what kind
of relationship you have with the women
for you I mean to use intimidation and
force to something sometimes you got a
gorilla pimp you feel me sometimes you
got to put your hands on a [ __ ] and let
a [ __ ] know that you ain't gonna play
with it you know what I'm saying cuz we
all out here taking penitential chances
for this [ __ ] so [ __ ] enough in the
play you feel me like you'd be a fool to
play games and you know I'm saying be
sitting in jail so if that's what we're
gonna do and that's the role that that's
that's life more than a 50% chance of
the role and yeah it's gonna play you
feel I have to put your hands on a baby
so it's like the best things to do is to
have your white dick if you have your
white [ __ ] or asian [ __ ] she a [ __ ]
that's not black if you have your
business not black I promise you you
ain't gonna have to put your hands on
her and she gonna bring you a little bit
of more money you know I'm saying when
you did on black [ __ ]
african-americans you know what I'm
saying you don't have to put your hands
on your intimidate them and that's just
because where we come from you feel me
it's like they due to the circumstances
and situations that I'm pimping you
hauling
I know you're real [ __ ] and you only
really need it so some [ __ ] some [ __ ] a
black man ain't gonna be some [ __ ] a
black man can't tell my black [ __ ] you
feel me like you you could tell it like
this like look go off the blade when
those shoes on [ __ ] you [ __ ] up you
feel me give me your shoes go stay down
your Fendi you can't you can't you can
you can't do that with a black [ __ ] but
you learn to put your hands on her first
you tell me because they like
they like this is crazy
what's the most violent you've ever had
to get with a girl say wow I used to be
a UH it was me and two of my partners
you feel me yeah we haven't we had a
little thing going on man
Rini take a film you saw any Beast I was
on our blades we're any gang been handle
work or no pet we suck do some little
[ __ ] to him you feel me I wanna say two
months and terminate myself
yeah there used to uh yeah long story I
want to get your trouble yeah long story
short again and we was guerilla pimping
man you film you better come up missing
you know what I'm saying for a couple of
days a couple of weeks whatever you want
to call it if she don't come back
correct you know I'm saying we was
dealing with dog kennels was dealing
with cat food we had a whole bunch of
ways to get a [ __ ] right in Philly like
you can't walk our blades and you
already gay you have to be paying
somebody [ __ ] you can't be out here
selling [ __ ] and you ain't paying no
money
you know what I'm saying you can easily
come up miss it forever
you know what I'm saying like this is
this [ __ ] real yeah my burning [ __ ]
with cigarette butts putting cigarettes
out on [ __ ] all type of [ __ ] man
they're pouring bleach no [ __ ] making
[ __ ] bathing bleach bath water
putting [ __ ] in the shower closing
the door on turn the hot water and
making them call you daddy
why don't wanna hot
you feel me and telling it like yeah you
know what I'm saying like hitman for now
and I'm daddy that's what you call me
know what I'm saying
while the hot water running on her and
she's screaming and all that [ __ ] you
filmed so you got a break they speery
still me once they spirit is broke
they eat capables blowing with
everywhere you know what I'm saying
that's real gorilla pimp but this levels
to the Shea from that's beginner's [ __ ]
after a while when you make a name for
yourself and all that change I'll do
that [ __ ] no more
but they say real man I don't know yeah
I don't get [ __ ] to some [ __ ] man for
sure
you